hello everybody and welcome back to the
things in the night my name is
markiplier we have a key we have an odd
don't know what it goes to yet I'm
pretty sure that it has something to do
with the East Wing in the lab but it's
so odd this key that I have I best
explore I'm pretty sure that it's one of
the doors back in the beginning of this
area but it's hard to say for sure what
diabolical horrors await me in the East
Wing yeah oh yeah what is my father been
doing here I must stop him it looks like
he's making tremendous advances in the
realm of science and technology also
magic this there's a lot of magic which
is weird and murder and monsters
[Music]
No
no no it's not gonna happen not gonna
happen
I will not allow this be careful how
this for careful I'll carefully throw
you wherever I feel like thank you ah
tool odd tool oh that's right you
wouldn't know what a what a screwdriver
it is that's so interesting but in my
coming doctor beams dr. Finn has been
treating on all of us really well
he gave us good sleeping quarters and
our own desk but I'm not liking what I'm
seeing some areas of the lab are
off-limits and sometimes I can hear
screams of terror but other than that
we've been treated really well dr. Finn
is a very smart man he's locked this
place down and killing us all I must say
he used us all damn him if anyone comes
here it's better you leave fast and burn
this place down
you can't save us haha I like how the
titles going well the entire time
[Music]
all right come here
stairs bank pardon me thank you door
fire all aye aye aye
there seriously nothing in any of these
I'm going to be superb ly offset if okay
nevermind I'm gonna be supremely upset I
got distracted by something there
something just truly you didn't see
nothing moves man
[Music]
was that a real moose man I don't think
it was a real news man I know and about
it I didn't think so
to dump an lamp yeah yeah okay
never mind I'll go upstairs is what I
wanted to do anyway who marquee new
Lackey Marquinho Lackey too many
statutes dead scientists locked doors
random closets
[Music]
oh boy that's a real one
how so bigoted to the closet I didn't
even notice something in running man I
hate man so much how did he get there
thought he went down the hallway
oh wow I mean my goodness bashing
[Music]
those are expensive you know oh thank
you the door that was locked
[Music]
what was in this room that you busted
out of hard to imagine there was still
strip Ivor's around over something this
man no okay moving on let's see what was
in that room that he smashed open this
guy hmm of this lady Oh doctor gab there
is something big and powerful in the
restricted area dr. Finn won't let any
oh sorry this is a female anyone in the
other three guys I've never seen before
and even they were never seen again
this was the first sign that something
was wrong with this place dr. Finn has
been trying to bring back the dead I
told him I wouldn't take part on such
crazy experiments and that I wanted to
get out of here
get out from there but he told me that
if I try and leave you would kill me and
then no one can know what we are doing
here I didn't like the way he was
looking at me so I told him I was sorry
and went back to work he has done it the
dead have risen he is mad we must get
out of here fast I'm going into the
restricted area and kill mr. Finn as
well that's the demon in there wish me
luck
I'll use Cornell and burn it down or die
trying
it look like you've died without even
starting so good job there lady should
look for some cornell the extremely
flammable explodey stuff that was
to almost kill me probably come ah yeah
I'm hesitant difficult system by someone
locked why why is it locked
for what reason I need more oil run out
geez and giving me any in a while yeah
since I got in this new area they
haven't give me a single drop but I will
persevere ah don't cause it in here ha
ha ha save me I got a box from it
because I was told this works feel like
a box in front of your face they can't
see you
I'm an experiment
[Music]
even though he's not even there oh this
is so stupid
it's so stupid what I'm about to do Oh
[Music]
give me out Oh
the stupidest thing I've ever done in my
entire life oh my god I was dumb dumb
dumb is he still there probably turn me
oh my goodness that's at Cornell let's
get some bait I know the difference aah
get away get away get away get away oh
okay I'll take it
ah why I mean we were you oh we don't
wanna I don't wanna okay all right
anyway um okay I got another problem in
here out of oil mannequins
where the heck did I go I missed I like
to skip a whole bunch of areas I'll
probably have to go back to Oh areas hi
buddy
hey I don't even hear them may be here
monsters it is there oh then now I
let's go around I'll decide get away get
away get away
you're a dick Buick dead people why I
should stop asking why I see dead people
it's obviously I have a sixth sense of
some sort
ah shut up stop texting me
busy busy God there's nothing here uh
why oh that's so good where's that guy
where's that monster was here right
I don't worry one seems just like
popping in and out of you all the time
and every door is locked
I'll prod cuz I I skipped all that part
below I probably missed out on like a
bajillion keys or something smoosh man
gone yeah huh
what that's right you ran away y'all saw
okay before I go up there let me go down
I'm almost out of oil seriously no job
man toast man no oil man yeah man don't
make me pull out hipsters market man why
am I afraid of closets now if this game
is just putting a bunch of new fears
into my brain that I've never had before
seriously I was not a big scared baby
before I started playing amnesia and now
it's like turned me into one stupid okay
I must have missed something
oh yeah when I was going down this way
and I tried the stupid box trick on
mousse man which did not work well maybe
it did work but I probably shouldn't
have been two feet from him when I tried
it oh my god again what a phone is
blowing up yeah all the ladies okay
there was nothing else down here all
right
okay all right there was nothing I asked
it bite nothing damn okay this way I
stuck oh it's dark I don't like dark
dark sucks wood dark Oh give me some oil
I did guess good oh that's not very much
thank you though I guess I should be
glad that they he's giving me anything
at all I should look
yes please oh this looks good I come up
here why more oil okay that's good
enough reason
[Music]
okay is that it wait that doesn't offend
it you gotta be kidding me
aha
[Music]
whoa what what was that barrel launched
the other barrel it was nobody like me
that wall that I could reproduce ah
there it is the other drill part now
what in the world would I need a drill
for all three oh yeah the handle that's
right I remember the last time I had
some other drill was like way back from
the original ending anyway watch these
lead skills huh
catch oh yeah
[Music]
I guess that's
anything down here in this room that I'm
item is like some more oil you know
cooking oil that I'm gonna stick in my
lamp and it totally work the same way
don't leg in there that's phenomenal
there's perfectly nice dead old pigs
there we go that's sensible put a pig
right in the oven everything just stuff
it in there or whatever there's got to
be like some key or something on one of
these gotta be right right
I mean it is right yeah totes McGee
music
[Music]
anyway I'm all out of time so I'll
figure this out in the next episode so
thank you everybody for watching and as
always we'll see you in the next farm
bye bye